Salut ! 22ème vidéo d'énigme
une énigme par jour pendant 32 jours
à l'intérieur du défi du mental vlog
c'était notre petit kiff de l'été
je vous donne une énigme par jour
mais avant de vous donner la nouvelle énigme, je vous donne la réponse d'hier
donc si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo d'hier regardez là d'abord.
La réponse à : "Qui a trouvé le moins d'énigme ?"
C'est Albert.
Et dans l'ordre ça donnait Julie, Naïs, David, Thomas et Albert.
Pas besoin de plus grande explication
si vous vérifiez toutes les prémisses que je vous donne au départ ça fonctionne
et c'est pourquoi on va passer directement à l'énigme d'aujourd'hui.
Énigme 22, oui c'est les 10 dernières énigmes là !
C'est une énigme qui mélange les maths très légères et la logique.
Je vous met au défi de trouver un nombre à 5 chiffres
qui respecte les contraintes que je vais vous donner.
Le 1er des 5 chiffres doit être la moitié du second.
Le 2ème chiffres doit être la moitié du 3ème.
Le 4ème chiffre est de 2 de moins que le 3ème et de 3 fois le dernier
et indice supplémentaire, la somme des 5 chiffres
si on additionnais les 5 chiffres du nombre, ça ferais 22.
Celleèci aussi c'est un énigme que vous pouvez résoudre
si vous mettez ça sur un papier si vous passez quelques minutes dessus
je suis sur que vous pouvez trouver le résultat.
Dès que vous l'avez trouvé, ne l'annoncez pas dans les commentaires
ou dites juste "j'ai trouvé".
Mais laissez un petit pouce en l'air
pour qu'on puisse voir le nombre de personnes qui auront réussi à résoudre l'énigme.
On approche de la fin du mois d'août
donc profitez encore un maximum de l'été.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir.
Voir même de partager cette vidéo
pour partager une énigme de temps en temps.
Ça fait plaisir !
Puisque le mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 11h !
Parce que demain c'est samedi.
Ciao !